I do really want the hate to stop I want
the picking sides and the abusive memes
and the language and all of that
I really hope on both sides it can stop
that's not why I made the video Tati
Westbrook addressing the aftermath of
her James Charles feud in another video
never in a million years but I think
that this situation would reach what it
did and I've just been at home
reflecting on all of this and really
when I made that video I I thought that
I would be the one that would take the
hit you know I thought I was going
against you know millions and millions
of subscribers she also further explains
why she put James on blast in the first
place it's about someone who reaches
across all platforms thirty million
people that are children dominantly
children and who is losing the ability
to get honest more and more each day the
last straw for me was the way I was
treated and our relationship was treated
with just zero respect this was just a
last-ditch effort for me to be really
loud and vocal and to wake up someone
that I really loved and still do before
they go and make some really serious
mistakes Tati says she doesn't hate
James though and doesn't want other
people hating on him either it's painful
to watch someone that you have cared
about be dragged and to know that this
all started because of me
and I don't think anyone deserves that I
just want you guys to know that there is
no celebration in what's happening I'm
just hoping that we can leave it at that
and close this up and that people can
drop this and move forward and let some
actual healing happen James Tati viewed
Damon do ahead days ago seemingly over
supplements James promoted sugarbear
hair
vitamins Tati owns halo Beauty vitamins
get off your high horse and have some
respect
James issued an apology to his bestie as
three years after that to tatiane James
Westbrook I'm sorry for everything that
is going on everything that I have put
you through over the past few weeks
but I was just like so gutted in the
aftermath of Vissel fiasco James has
lost millions of youtube subscribers and
followers including Miley Cyrus and
Kylie Jenner says ego is so big that he
will think that everything is about him
taja also criticized James's off-camera
behavior oh my god you tried to trick a
straight man into thinking he's gay yet
again and somehow you're the victim I'm
so disappointed in myself that I ruined
our relationship that did mean so much
to me
even if I didn't do the best job of
showing it all the time I wish that I
could say this with the last time that I
would make a mistake
but it won't be I'm just handling it day
by day and try my absolute best and of
course learning from my mistakes and
it's a learning process there's no guide
book on how to do this it's just be
yourself and hopefully people yeah are
there for the ride
[Music]